Nation uh we are waiting now Mr Victor
wanyama I just want to read these
numbers off to you because there were
high expectations he is number one
amongst rookies with 20.6 points per
game he is number one in rebounds at
10.1 he is number one in blocks not just
amongst rookies in the entire NBA and
now he is number one in the show rundown
Victor wanyama joining us an absolute
honor to have you here Victor this is
leco and and my question is this the
other day we saw do the biggest sham God
that we have ever seen and I think we
all assumed when you came into the
league you were going to be watching
clips of hakee and big men and that made
me realize that you weren't what YouTube
clips were you watching when you were
growing up who were the players that you
emulated uh first of all thanks for
having you guys and uh yeah it's
uh I've been watching uh a whole lot of
different players not just one but
lately I'm I'm seeing in the past couple
years I'd say say jannis and Kevin
Durant are really top players I've
watched but way before you know I looked
at plenty of guys I can't name him all
and you knew when did you did you know
that this was called the Sham God cuz
what you did to Rudy goar was phenomenal
to watch yeah in Europe we we we usually
call it the body Rog more but I knew it
was a
shame wimy how you doing Vince Carter
here question for you what has been the
biggest adjustment for you uh I know you
came in you said Hey I'm fine I'm
looking forward to this but what has
been the biggest adjustment in the NBA
so far for
you uh you know very simply uh you know
the different play style from what I
knew um I had to I had to take a step up
in uh the quality of shots the way I
move on the court the way I take my
positions so this is very basketball
stuff you know but one of the biggest
thing is uh how hard of a fight it is
every night uh and you know you barely
have time to rest I'm saying more
mentally than physically you know you
got to fight and go back against against
Rudy Gober against Janis against LeBron
night after night and this is I would
say this is the biggest battle we fight
as NB players WB this is Jamal cord I
always say seeing you in person you're
the created player that created players
would create and I love watching you
play but actually seeing you after the
game I was leaving the arena and I saw
you in the weight room right after and
to me that was even more impressive
where dides your drive and your focus
come
from you know um to me it's it's very
clear but at the same time is it's kind
of you know intimate I'd say it's very
profound you know inside of me it's uh
you know I I got this this abilities I
got this Talent you know I'm I'm healthy
I'm I was raising a good family you know
and uh so I got all this that was given
to me and for me the the only option is
to use it and to make the most out of it
so if I if I can be the best then I must
be the
best Wy Candace Parker here um you know
you you you come from basketball
overseas and we've had players that have
made the jump um recently uh Luca donic
who has said that when you get to the
NBA everything opens up a little bit
it's a little more clustered over in
overseas and he said it's a little bit
easier playing in the NBA what can you
tell me about the difference between
playing overseas and then coming to the
NBA um of course it is different you
know the scoring aspect might be easier
but it's definitely not easier to play
and to to perform in the NBA and uh I
would say as a rookie as well there's
there's some adaptation time you know I
mean coming from different background
than most college players for example
but you know just coming from Europe
This an adaptation time but it is
different the spacing is way more open
and uh you know guys are way more
talented you know here wmy Jamal again
left Co brought up that you brought out
the Sham God can you do the Crawford
double behind the back shake and bake
can you do that move in a game if you do
you oh no doubt no hesitation is that a
doubt he said yes can we see that
season that the coach I had in France
his name is kareim that that taught me
the the shamard for example he also
taught me the double behind the back
shaking bake so this and this is
something I work on
so if you pull that out if you pull that
out will you be first on Cross I may
have to show you the extended version
I've never shown anybody but I'mma hand
that gift to you because you can do it
and you will take it to the masses
congrats my brother appreciate it thank
you I say I've watched film of you doing
it like compilations stuff
unbelievable Victor wama an absolute
pleasure congratulations they take on
the magic tomorrow we'll see you in
Indianapolis thank you guys thanks for
having me yeah man uh now we're going to
go and we're going to get a live look in
Jamal Jamal how did that feel that that
was crazy yeah if he pulls that move out
I promise you I said I had 10 moves I've
never pulled out I will give him the one
of the 10 that's part of that move so
you have moves that you just never
Unleashed absolutely I was waiting until
I made All-Star game I never made it I
can't imagine Vince now it's folklore I
promise you I will give him that move
and then before we get to CarMax what is
it like knowing that this guy who's
going to be the future of the NBA is
watching your film and being like I need
to dribble like Jamal it's crazy because
Candace and I were talking last night
and we were talking about different
people and impact they've had in
actually growing the game and we both
agreed that he can actually grow the
game forward so for him to even you know
know he can do that move and acknowledge
this crazy your favorite player's
favorite player but you're their
favorite player stop she got bars stop
it stop saying that's kind of crazy all
right CarMax 101 let's talk about
the